i want to start with carolina panthers
we saw kyle allen throw four
interceptions on sunday against the
atlanta falcons the panthers are now
five and five remember last year chris
they were six and two and they fell
apart this year five and three and in
the midst of falling apart in the second
half david tepper owning the team met
with charlotte reporters on monday and
he said that no decision has been made
yet about cam newton for next year but
the open they're open to the idea of
bringing him back it's not exactly what
you expect to hear from an owner of a
team that has a franchise quarterback
right yeah um and and it makes it it
creates the impression everything is in
flux 19.1 million dollar compensation
package easily tradeable because there's
plenty of teams out there that would
love to have cam newton right and agree
and this may just be a situation where
it's time for a fresh start for everyone
involved i agreed maybe that is it i
mean i just think the fact that you know
david pepper acknowledges that
no decision has been made yet obviously
tells you that there is a decision to be
made and that they're having these
conversations and these thoughts are
there which uh i find that kind of
interesting in the fact that he just
revealed that alone you know they're
they're in a weird spot kyle has done
some good things now but i don't look at
kyle allen still at this point and at no
point did i ever look at it and go oh
he's the future
you know they've got a good team a good
system around him norv turner's done
really well
but my big thing would be you know hey
again franchise quarterbacks and guys
that we're talking about going to make
30 million dollars a year and things
like that when things don't go well can
he carry you and make plays uh to get
your offense through some bad times and
to me that's where i would question kyle
allen a little bit certainly um and you
know and the other thing mike to like to
this is carolina is playing just good
enough to where
they're not going to leave themselves in
the position to get you know a joe
burrow or a justin herbert who i think
is the best quarterback coming out in
the draft from oregon you know and of
course now tua and that situation's all
you know in flux and we'll see where it
goes um i do think cam newton's been
disrespected through this process to a
degree by other coaches uh and people
even trying to insinuate that kyle allen
was better than cam newton is just
absolutely insane but i'm with you it
might be that time where both needed
just a fresh start and a new look for
their for their for their singular self
and cam newton and the organization in
the carolina panthers
part of the problem chris is that with
cam newton he's either injured or if
he's healthy there's a fear he's going
to be injured again and i think that
develops for the fan base and maybe for
the organization a certain amount of
fatigue yes you're constantly worried
about when is the next time cam newton's
not going to be able to play or we're
worried about using him as a runner oh
we're worried about him taking hits oh
no hold your breath and you'd like to
get away from that at some point the
colts and andrew luck even though they
would have liked to have kept andrew
luck around there's a certain
relief that sets in when you're no
longer obsessed week in and week out
with the health of your quarterback and
there are plenty of other teams
that would
happily have a quarterback who may or
may not have injury issues because when
he does play he's going to be a lot
better than the guys that they currently
have available to them so this could get
very interesting and here's the other
side of it too you can't make a decision
about cam newton until you know who's
going to be making the decision we don't
know who's going to be making the
decision because david tepper also
did not make that sweeping long-term
commitment to his gm and his head coach
he just bought the team a year ago he
may decide after this season it's time
to move on from either marty herney or
ron rivera until you know who's going to
be making your decisions you can't even
begin to make a decision about cam
newton uh that that's a very good point
mike you're right so uh we don't know
where that's gonna go and maybe the
vision of the next offensive coordinator
and head coach and what they got in
store for what they want as a as a
football team um
you know cam newton nonetheless you know
yes he's banged he he he played last
year right he was banged up and sucked
it up and played and of course it didn't
add you know lead to good things this is
really the first year where he's missed
big chunks of games throughout his
career you know other than that he's
been healthy but to what you're saying
mike i think it's totally well but chris
chris he did play through it last year
but he was it got worse and worse and
worse first out
i know i said that you must have not
been listening to me once again i was
listening but i i mean but to your point
i i totally agree with you that decision
does is a tough one because we're
getting towards the
part of his career and he's getting to
that age where you start to wonder oh is
it gonna be one thing after another with
all the pounding that his body has taken
through the years so i think that's a
very legitimate question but i do think
we both agree
that there would be some teams that
would entertain the idea of him coming
down right the bears chargers right
i mean the tennessee titans we'll see
what they do i mean you know those are
three teams that right off the bat just
jump out to me
as possible patriots uh okay maybe i
don't tom brady at least if tom brady
leaves you're right okay okay cameron's
two and oh against the patriots bro
you're when you we know that two and are
out of the way to devise an offense to
help him out and play to his strengths
as well i mean we clearly know that so
you're right if tom brady's out of there
i will not throw that out there i know
you said the tampa bay buccaneers too if
they thought jameis winston uh was not
the answer and he left town so i i get
all of those i think that there's a very
real possibility of any that happen hey
maybe the miami dolphins want to go that
route if they can't get in position to
get a quarterback they want in the draft
or whatever but uh i i uh this is going
to be interesting to watch here as this
the rest of the season unfolds and i
think a lot will depend on what kai
allen does down the stretch and how he
responds to some of these bad games he's
just recently had
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports